I missed one years of age and have
almost a billion citizens either in
office sixty-two years making me the
longest-serving monarch in history have
we first
Abdul you will travel to England
to the royal household you will present
the Queen with a ceremonial coin
whatever you do you must not look at her
majesty there's a famine in India I
minister you really are terribly
depressing yes
Jay your majesty I suddenly feel a great
deal better she has her customs to
careen be her personal footman how do
you like your Scottish costumes they're
very Scratchy
everything in Scotland is fractured what
can we be talking about which is a mango
the queen of folk I'm not a man down
there any grave a ninja
well I'm Empress of India so I have one
self no one really knows what it's like
to be queen mother you're spying on me
everyone about to start I just go on at
all what is the point
sous your most we are here for a greater
purpose you are a servant no longer they
will teach me I do and the Koran upset
the order of everything throughout this
Indian peasants or we will have you
certified insane
and computers
[Music]
greedy that I am the house disagreeably
attached to power but I am anything but
insane I am queen of Eden
and precision game
a bruising on his own merits now he is
my friend
I haven't been as happy as this for
years a little surprise what is it a
mango your majesty
it's off Samri this mango is off
[Music]